really maddening friends since like
literally forever we were really young
and watching her kind of have to figure
out all these little things along the
way has been really helpful for me first
of all how are you do it with all of
this how are you feeling right now I'm
feeling okay I think generally it's just
kind of like I'm perfectly okay with
staying inside I'm used to staying
inside it's kind of like my my thing but
as long as like everyone is staying safe
I think that's the main priority exactly
we all just got to do our part where are
you
quarantined right now and who are you is
right now I'm quarantined all alone
which is you know a recipe for disaster
and I'm just in my house in LA oh it's
exactly how I feel are you what are you
doing to pass the time I mean I want to
talk about the new album but are you one
of those artists who's constantly
writing even though you just put out an
album or how are you kind of spending
hours yeah I'm I started writing
[Music]
I mean I never stopped writing so I
can't even say I got like the second I
finished my album I finished kid crow on
December 5th on my birthday and then I
was writing songs December 6 and so it's
like you know I just I'm always writing
and I'm spending all my time right now
writing songs which is kind of hard
because there's like literally nothing
to write about like what am I gonna
write like sitting in my house but like
I'm just done yeah I'll figure it up
[Music]
- I do want to talk about kid crow
because it is freaking phenomenal what
was it like though it's an album sort of
amid this pandemic I mean you probably
couldn't do all the press that you
wanted to do all the provo that you
wanted to do so kind of walk me through
that yeah I mean I think I was a little
bit kind of nervous just like all of all
of the press service was to do you know
like playing TV shows together all that
like got cancelled but um I don't know
what I'm I'm an Internet kid like I was
fully raised on the Internet
I started writing songs and putting them
up on you know when I was 12 years old
so like it felt very fitting that I
released the whole album just like live
streaming on my computer I mean I was
nervous obviously just cuz I was putting
on my album I was like oh no all my
secrets are gonna be revealed but I
don't know it was felt very
comfortable.that I did it up on the
Internet
[Music]
I know boy and a boy best friends with
each other so you talked about putting
the album out and how you felt like all
these secrets we're gonna come out I
mean now that it is out in the world and
it's resonating so much with people like
what do you think it is about your
lyrics that people are connecting to so
much not sure I think I'm literally just
like my album and when I write it's just
my diary like literally I don't even
think at all like about the fact that
people are gonna be listening um which I
I mean maybe I think that when you're
honest in songwriting it resonates with
people cuz like we're all human we all
have a lot of the same issues kind of no
matter who you are so um I try to be as
honest as possible but who knows I mean
if I knew exactly what made people like
my music I think I'd have broken the
code of the universe so maybe it's a
good thing that I don't know that yeah
what was the big inspiration or what
were the experiences that you were
writing about with this album that
really helped you put words to paper I
think that mostly the whole album is
just kind of like a coming-of-age oven
like if you can think of the album in a
movie it's very much like a like you
know adolescent coming-of-age story um
it's like you know I fall in love for
the first time Sallah out of love for
the nine millionth time and my heart
broken because that's my main goal in
life is to get my heart broken
apparently according to my standards
getting older and like you know moving
out of my hometown in Texas which is
like a really small town and like just
kind of everything that goes along with
growing up um and kind of my life story
like everything that happened before you
know my childhood which was I had a
pretty tough childhood so kind of like
talking about that for the first time I
burned my music as well oh yeah what was
the hardest to put on the album I think
the hardest subject was talking about my
past I'm the kind of person that when I
think about you know my childhood I'm
just like hey I'm gonna really just like
force it out of my brain
and I'd never really talked about it in
a song before but there's a song on the
album called his story both our fans
were evil so we both made a bet where I
like really talk about everything that
happened growing up and growing up in
Texas and all the things that happen to
me and my friends I was really scared to
put out because I was afraid I said a
little bit too much but in the end it's
like if I say something that maybe makes
me uncomfortable that makes other people
find solace in me like I think it's
worth it what was it about your
childhood that was so rocky or
tumultuous for you and you feel like
songwriting helped you to process that
part of your life yeah
songwriting was literally the only
reason why I stayed afloat um it was
just really like I just didn't really
have much of a family or like a support
system which is confusing when you're
like nine and you're like but I I had a
lot of really good friends and you know
family is always a confusing thing for
people I think no matter who you are my
sister and my mom and stuff like that we
were kind of just like on our own taking
care of ourselves so it was um it's
confusing and also moved around like a
billion times all the time and um it was
just it was a confusing childhood yeah
but writing songs about it and writing
almost in general is like my way of
dealing with all the craziness
[Music]
people who I want to say inspired some
of these songs like how do they feel
when they hear the album or do you even
talk to them about that well I wrote a
lot of the songs about my best friend
Ashley back home in Texas and she she
thinks it's really annoying that I said
my people the people that like that like
you know broke my heart have definitely
heard the album because I like I'm kind
of testy Alex and then the songs of life
I think it's funny I don't care whatever
there's definitely satisfaction and like
taking a situation that made me feel
really horrible and like making it the
best thing ever it's fun but it's also
speaking of getting our hearts broken I
saw on your Instagram you posted a clip
of you singing online love what is
dating actually like for you in
quarantine right now like are you
getting on the apps or like what's that
process like I definitely am NOT going
on any app side echoed literally get
obliterated I think I killed not doing
that but I think nicely I mean I don't
know I'm horrible at dating like have
you heard the song then I'm horrible at
it I don't know I don't know maybe I
can't date at all I'm really bad at it
it is I mean it is hard and I will say
like your tweets have really made me lol
like when you talk about dating there
was one that you wrote a couple days ago
I think I wrote it out you said I love
horrible toxic disgusting people they
make my heart go whoosh is that really
high
I know I know it's self destructive but
also like what am I gonna write a song
about if I'm just like super in love
like no you want to write like I'm gonna
burn your house also like it takes
special takes a special kind of horrible
person to make you like really question
your existence and that's good for
songwriting that is good for songwriting
um you also I think it was like 2018 you
tweeted about labels and like why are
people so consumed with labels and I
really love that because I think we're
in a time right now we're like why are
we putting labels on like people and
sexuality and anything like just let
people be who they want to be do you
still feel that way and and why was that
important for you to say I think we live
in a really special time now where
people can be whoever they want to be
and you know the youth earned that
privilege by a lot of people who died
and fought for us to be able to say you
can't be like we don't really want to
have labels and and we have the
privilege of not having to have anymore
so I think it's I think it's really
special and really important and it
shows a lot of progress in in the world
which makes me really happy yeah I agree
with that also you and I have something
very major in common in that we are both
huge Taylor Swift fans like I'm the
ultimate swifty my Twitter profile
swifty on there she is of your music
what was it like to get that recognition
from the freaking Queen I mean it was so
special its III was mind blown I'm still
I still haven't really processed that it
actually happened but when it happened I
like texted my best friend back home and
we were just like what is going on like
why is this happening um she's she's one
of my favorite song writers of all time
I literally you know since I was like 9
or 10 years old have been listening to
her songs and she's soundtrack of my
life since I was so young so it's such a
privilege and I definitely fan boid as
much as I wanted to I was like I deserve
that I have the right to fanboy
like this is that this is Taylor Swift
no she's just so talented we know the
moment that she really kind of fell in
love with your music do you remember the
moment that you fell in love with her
music
absolutely I remember that it was the
first time I ever saw her the first
youtube video I ever watched was um the
music video drops on my guitar and I
immediately was just like who is this
girl like I love her curly hair I want
to be her best friend I want her to be
my sister like I want her to be my mom I
don't even know like it was like so many
emotions she's I think it's just like
really special watching her you know
grow up I'm writing songs for all of us
to kind of like learn about love I heard
which is so cool yeah you did say I
guess she like slid into your DMS just
to congratulate you I mean what does it
like DMing with her and like what types
of conversations do you guys have oh
well she's she's just very very sweet
and she said some super nice things
about the album and um it's like you
know I was really nervous about the
album ah I've never made an album before
I have no idea how to make it now
buttons so to have someone who's made so
many like groundbreaking incredible
albums tell me that they liked my album
is just like everything I could have
ever asked for so um she's one my
favorite people on earth yeah I mean
mine too were you now we know that lover
Fest has been sadly postponed not
canceled just postponed but were there
talks of you potentially possibly
performing at lover fest I would love to
um I don't really know but um I just I
really really want to go because I've
never been to a Taylor Swift show in my
life all of my friends have gone I've
never been I've watched every single
documentary I've watched every single
live video you could ever think of I've
seen but I've never been and I just
really I can't even imagine how fun it
would be so I really
want to go someone else that I have to
talk to you about is Billy Eilish
because she is a huge fan of yours has
she talked to you at all about sort of
navigating Fame now that you're like on
this insane path to superstardom and for
her it happened so quickly yeah I mean
um billion I've been friends since like
literally forever like since since she
was like 15 I was like 17 like we were
really young and watching her kind of
have to figure out all these little
things along the way has been really
helpful for me because I think it's nice
to find solace and the other people of
like this is a crazy thing that happens
like it's a really confusing thing and
it can be really terrifying at times and
I know watching her um just you know
work so hard and also like all the
things that have happened along the way
it has been really um eye opening and
she's so talented and she works so so so
hard and she's one of my favorite people
ever and it's very nice to have people
you know who are in a situation where
they can they can give you a little bit
of advice and a little bit of help and a
little bit of what what has she said to
you I think we both just kind of joke
about how crazy it is like it's just
ridiculous it's just trying to find a
little bit of normalness and all this
crazy stuff are you ready for this next
level of super stardom or does it make
you anxious I think I'm I mean I think
all of this makes me nervous
I'm not unnaturally like I'm not like
look at me like it if it was up to me I
would literally be completely invisible
no one like no one could see me no one
could sense that I was in existence um
so it's been it's been yeah absolutely I
was so scared of people I've been a shy
person my whole life I've always kind of
like watched people but not really
participated and in life so it's scary
but also I think it's like I have my
friends back home in Texas like east
show grounded and they're so important
to me and like all of my other friends
and all my artists friends like we're
all in this together like
trying our best to kind of find footing
in this when people listen to your album
what do you want them like maybe three
things that you want people to learn
about who you are as a as a person I
hope that they relate I hope I don't
sound too crazy I think all I ever
really wants people to like look at me
be like hey Conan like you're not that
crazy like you're a little crazy but
like you'll be fine like this is fine
[Music]
and also I think like the album is my
way of like connecting with my fans and
telling them all of my secrets and my
fans mean everything to me so I just
hope that the fan bees find a little bit
of comfort and that they can scream them
in their car and stuff like that no
that's a lie
[Music]